hi there Steve Kaufman here two weeks
into my 90 day challenge challenging the
language of poland polish I've been
working heavily with the material from
Piazza from real polish which I
mentioned last time both his hundred
stories which are great and his podcast
I've been reading or downloading content
from her ah do polski the audio doesn't
necessarily match the text but I'm
reading the text my vocabulary have
increased mine own words by I've added
five thousand words to mine own words in
polish and i have saved another four
thousand words and phrases so those are
words that i'm studying but i might have
might know half of them i'm sure up to
about eight thousand words or so in two
weeks but that's based on knowing
ukrainian and chess some you know
ukrainian checkin and russian i don't
think i could do that in you know
turkish and next year I'm going to go
after a language that's unrelated to
anything I've ever studied it might be
Turkish it might be Arabic I don't know
yet or Greek or something anyway so I'm
enjoying elders material I'm listening a
lot i'm going to start answering his
material the hundred stories which I
think are brilliant or he said don't
study grammar just do the stories you
listen to a story you listen to the
point of view a different point of view
and then you have these questions which
I have not up until now been answering
out loud and he's he says you know if
you if you please suggest we answer out
loud but we don't have to we don't want
to so initially I haven't been and i
think i'm going to start doing that so
that for the next little while i'm going
to continue you know i want to get
myself out of my comfort zone in terms
of vocabulary by reading things i've
ordered a book on on polish history i've
gone to the wikipedia page of polish
history i've imported all that into link
and going through because i'm interested
in history gaining words and phrases
from the radio site from the history
sites and so forth and at the same time
I'm going and I'm doing the
easier material that Peter has in his
hundred stories so I'm sort of a
two-track here and since I'm now quite
familiar with all the vocabulary and
filters stories having import them all
into link and created links and stuff
now i'm going to start actually
answering out loud i might do it just
listening or i might do it while i'm
reviewing in sentence view on the ipad
so i can actually read you know the
individual question or i can say the
answer and then go to the next sentence
see the answer say it again so all of
these kinds of things are going to be
doing a to increase my vocabulary but
also to prepare myself for speaking
because come the beginning of october or
soon into october i want to have a
conversation with guilt questions send
me your questions just when i say send
them just put your questions here at
YouTube will gather them up and once a
week I try to answer them so thank you
and I hope you're all working hard on
your 90 day challenge thanks for
listening bye for now